yeah do a real a real assessment of the
fight on Saturday so okay McGregor vs.
Mayweather yeah you go first right from
the very beginning you said he's going
early rounds early you know Connors
gonna get the early rounds he's gonna
preserve preserve preserve and he's
gonna walk him down after you know the
fifth or sixth round and that's exactly
what he's it's like saying um age you
know that Cristiano Ronaldo beat LeBron
James and soccer you're like yeah but
LeBron James doesn't play soccer that's
right
Cristiano one it's two different sports
okay and it was a money [ __ ] event we
all paid for it when I went to the
comedy store afterwards there was no one
in the audience I swear to god it was
that and 12 people I think I heard like
one in five Americans was watching it
yeah that's so they made a lot of
[ __ ] money right and good for you but
I will not be tricked again it was um
you knew that Mayweather was gonna win
because that's his sport it's a sport
but I everybody always buys Mayweather
fights because they hate Mayweather they
want to see him lose they don't people
don't get mayweather fights because oh
they're super exciting they don't cuz
he's undefeated like I remember watching
him and De La Hoya and everybody was out
of their seats because Mayweather lost
the first four rounds yeah yeah and
they're like oh my god he's gonna do it
it's always the same thing he always
takes you into the later rounds and
that's when he you know he just picked
you apart the one thing I will say I was
surprised about is you know I don't know
I mean how much of boxing or fighting
you guys know but like Conor referred to
him as fighting like a Mexican yeah yeah
and you know that's because the mesh
hands hands up and just swinging the
entire time and he did he did fought
like a Mexican he didn't fight you know
his normal shell slipping punches in
counter he came forward the entire time
so I mean may whatever the thing was it
was it was a perfect game plan because
being a counter fighter and constantly
have to
by going backwards it'll tire you out
yeah because Mayweather probably threw
ten punches the first floor like you
throw any punches yeah you know and
everybody gets excited when you know
they're hitting has got but a lot most
so Connors punches didn't land because I
rewatched the fight and they a lot of
them didn't he gotta talk to you there
yeah he got a couple nice uppercuts in
there but he wore him out and once he
wore him out yeah you know it's the same
thing with the the Nate Diaz fight oh
yeah you know first round he doesn't
face your honor does a face and you know
he's gonna lose yeah you called it space
where he turns around he like wobbles
the color of his skin changes he goes
from a very red to sort of a pale type
of low gas blowing his eyes get droopy
very alert and then when he gets here
yeah you know wow that's good ah what
did you think about the stoppage I
thought it was early for boxing theory
for UFC or every for every forever I
mean for everything I would say for both
but what you got to understand is they
got the three knockdown rule yes of
course yeah but a lot of times that's
you know knockdowns happen there light
flash knockdowns you know there's a wild
exchange somebody gets hit with one
punch they get floored they have an
opportunity to get up you know the ref
makes sure's that they're they're
conscious and they're they're ready to
fight sometimes stoppage is like the the
Conor Mayweather happen just because
when a rough seas of fighters completely
out of it yeah and like exhausted and if
they're not defending themselves
it's they're doing it for the fighter
yeah you know because let's face it they
kind of let that fight keep going yeah
Connor wasn't confident he was gonna get
now he would have gone more like he
would have got he would got beat up yeah
my question to you is now I know like I
don't know the insides of what
contractually you know what they sign up
for could you put that into in the
contracts for someone like McGregor like
if he's if he's visibly hurt mm-hmm that
we don't do like the three three
knockdown rule like can you put that in
the contract I you know I don't think so
I just think Commission wise the the
rules are what they are I don't think
they can exempt anybody like Connor
knows what
getting himself into I don't I don't
think anything like because how many
seconds were left on a clock
20 or something like it wasn't a lot 20
but what round was that there's two
rounds left yeah he would have got
knocked out that's that's unnecessary
damage okay though did you not think so
no no he did he did great yeah I'm even
some of the you know I don't like the
condescending announcers or like he's
pretty good his job was pretty you know
I mean like as if he's never funny but
I'm nowhere but let me tell you
something boxing guys um the UFC is that
where it's at that's where the level is
so don't be condescending well they
should because he can do more cut high
kicks to the face if that's where it's
at then the writers should be paid the
way boxers are getting paid well and you
know in in Connors defense MMA we have
to train for so many other things yeah
so like boxing all they're doing is
boxing the Mayweather's never thrown a
kick he's never had to Train wrestling
jujitsu so we have to split up our time
training doing a bunch of dudes so our
conditioning is also different you
notice a lot of MMA fighters we kind of
hold more muscle we're a little more
bulky because there's more grappling
there's more wrestling strength is a
bigger issue boxing you know they have a
big core but their arms are kind of
skinny here you know just because it's a
specific skill set so I mean I respect
Conor for going in and I mean he fought
the best bot in my eyes he's the best
boxer you ever lived you know he he's on
me he's unbeaten you know okay and he
landed more punches than anybody else
really has so if you would have fought
Pacquiao a little earlier now in your
packet yeah I mean yeah I mean he he
lost it for me with that because
Mayweather call them out after Pacquiao
had already lost them yeah I hear you I
hear you I agree with the point - yeah I
agree with you yeah yeah I agree with
that and to me it's like I don't listen
when you see somebody like who's the
[ __ ] Samoan that I like mark mark
pilot mark hunt record is Garland
I want to watch him fight because he's
gonna put it on the line something's
gonna happen the one-hit knockouts are
awesome yeah and so walk off so someone
like Mayweather who is undefeated
it doesn't really because I've seen this
fights it's like I know what you do
you're very good defensively you're you
you are a precision strut striker later
on in the rounds and um you're very good
at what you do but you're not fun to
watch well I said it I said me from a
fighter standpoint I like watching me
whether fight yeah because I pick up on
a lot of subtleties a lot of thing
little things in there that people don't
pick up on if I wasn't just a normal
average man casual casual fan hanging I
don't wanna I'm not paying I'm not gonna
support it I'm not gonna pay a hundred
bucks at because if I want to be
entertained it's not entertaining like I
said it's not his boxing style that
people pay to watch people pay to watch
him lose and that's why everybody's
super excited when Connors went in more
rounds they're like he may do it he may
do it you know
[Music]